greetings everyone so
i'm robert kennedy president of the
tennessee valley stellar corporation you
can find us at www.stellacorp.tv
i would like to dedicate this talk to
two persons who cannot be here
one is my late father third assistant
engineer on the nuclear ship savannah
he appreciated big metal at the cutting
edge of science and engineering i think
he would have liked this
meeting we're having here today and the
other is
all of our mutual friend the late great
john wharton who was in on the geo
engineering from the very beginning 21
years ago
so welcome one and all
we are talking about geoengineering
so let's
get right into it
what's the problem well
problem simple governments worldwide
have shown themselves
pretty much incapable of working
together
effectively
to deal with climate change
now if we cannot kick our carbon habit
as individuals or nation-states
then uh
we should and can deploy a sun shade
in space
to cool the planet
sometime hence
now such a shade craft
will be
huge
size of texas and it'll take decades to
build
in order to have this capability this
technology ready by mid-century
which is about the time
often say
that we better start doing something
we can buy a long-term option of
starting
technology development right now
thank you
so
um
i
was the lead author
lead author on a 2013 article in journal
of the british interplanetary science um
society
on the design and construction of a
large shade craft that we dubbed dyson
dots and anyone who wants a copy of this
just contact me by email offline k3 it's
stellar
dot tv
this article uh nine years ago remains
the leading authority in the field we
did a mass budget an economic cost
benefit calculation and never had
even the germans say it hasn't been
improved and they use it and when
germans say you're credible that's
you know
you're good
in addition
in my day job
i've been doing green energy all over
the world for interesting people all
over the world
helping
scientists and engineers in developing
economies
build stable teams keyword stable teams
to develop their own renewable energy
resources
for their benefit over the long term
and these experiences
have led me to pursue
this goal by starting technology
development on a prototype
let's move
okay
we have created the tennessee valley
stellar corporation a non-profit entity
to cooperatively design and launch
prototype shadecraft called
dysonpicodox
the project will operate
at a stable radiated radiation levitated
orbit that means
where light does the propelling
near the sun earth lagrange point which
is a magic gravitational point
these pico dots are based on cubesat
technologies and are newly accessible to
small organizations
that's
why now
why we didn't do it in 2013
because
the necessary elements
didn't exist yet in 2013
but now they do three things have
emerged which are transforming the world
especially in this in this
thought space
one
a cubesat is
a cube ten centimeters on a side four
inches
the important thing is
it's a physical application programming
interface henceforth referred to as api
there's another api you can see on the
slide in front of you the second picture
the shipping container
which has physically transformed the
world arguably
more than chips or the internet have
because anywhere a four-wheel truck can
get the entire world economy can reach
out and touch you via a shipping
container
now
in cubesats there's two forms of
standardization or interoperability
there's above
which means inter a common interface
with the launcher
so every rocket in the world now expects
that they may have a cubesat as a
ride-along passenger and there's a
common interface that everybody knows
how to deal with it's much like having a
plug that you know is going to go into
the wall to run your device
and then there's
downward
standardization which is to say
in the cubesat market
um a marketplace has exist
with
numerous pre-built
off-the-shelf components
so the great thing about standardization
is it alleviates the pain of dealing
with interface issues
so that the
in fact i'll take a brief assign dr
allison mentioned at the top of the call
how it is that uh scientists and
engineers have because
been forced to become
videographers and learn all this
all these video presenting tricks
that is an example of interface pain
so the great thing about standardization
is
it removes the pain from the interface
matters and allows the team to
concentrate on the stuff they're good at
and the stuff that's novel in their
mission which might be a small fraction
of the mass of the spacecraft but it's
where
it's where the purpose of the spacecraft
is
cubesats have enabled the creation of
things and capabilities in space
that are directly interacted with by
people on the ground
for example
planet.com
operates an array of about 100
cubesats about the size of a quart of
milk a little larger with a telescope in
them a hundred that essentially do
a line scan of planet earth every 24
hours and then they make this available
to absolutely everybody who's willing to
pay a modest fee
recently open source intelligence
is being relied on in the war in ukraine
by their citizens soldiers publicly
available open source intelligence
including publicly available synthetic
aperture radar sets which provide an
all-weather
imaging capability photo reconnaissance
capability in near real time to the
citizen soldiers fighting on the ground
which is changing the world
that war is
not going the way
anyone expected just two and a half
months ago
now our dyson
pico dot project
it's it's but one
mission
of a space program of the tennessee
valley stellar corps space program or
stellar corp for short that's a mouth
the program is
our program is cooperative not
authoritarian
it may be possible
to build a small satellite
with a small team in a in an
authoritarian manner
but
30 40 50 years from now when the human
race needs to build an actual full-scale
dyson dot
the size of texas or school of them the
size of texas that is absolutely not
possible without cooperation among the
entire
human race
now it's techies here in silicon valley
no especially at stanford university one
model of social cooperation that has
proven itself over a long time is linux
which is an enduring
open source project
ubiquitously embedded even in
proprietary closed corporations so
whatever their external product line is
that they're selling to the public what
they actually run inside is linux
because it works
sometime between the 1970s and now
we went our community went
from centralized mainframes
to
smartphones with apps
that can do
anything
a user could possibly want wish or
imagine
[Music]
from anywhere in the world
this represents an absolute phase change
in
one's ability
to mobilize resources and bring them
there on a project
a
surprisingly
small
amount of resources
so
the
tennessee stellar corp
will inspire
this enormous untapped resource around
the world of or regular but technically
proficient people
who've who have demonstrated the ability
the ability to work effectively remotely
contrary to traditional management
expectations
because of the pandemic
that's turned management wisdom upside
um not just upside upside down
and i can tell you from personal
experience many corporations have made
irreversible decisions to capture the
economic benefits of that downsizing
their commercial real estate and having
everyone work from home
and in fact centers of excellence for
space exploration
have emerged completely outside of
traditional
power centers you know the giant
bureaucracies and the giant
multi-billion contractors
one example that our organization is
quite familiar with
is the ransac project ram sat
for
robertsville middle school
which was conceived
designed
fabricated assembled
launched
deployed and is now successfully being
operated at this minute
by 12 year olds
in our at the robertsville middle school
in our town of oakridge
tennessee
this is the youngest team in history
to ever execute a satellite project of
any kind if you want a metric it took
them four years
and seventy thousand dollars u.s
and a couple of gifted mentors and one
shop teacher who was a real visionary
so
this is just an extraordinary
downward push
the third major emergence especially in
the last five years is pretty much
a universal
disenchantment disappointment with
elites with elite's ability to run
things
and if it depresses you to read the
newspaper no
you're not helpless
you can't help
yourself by working with us
institutions are dysfunctional i mean
after having
please like uh young miss dunberg from
sweden
repeatedly explain tell the world that
we're in bad shape and wish
witnessing that dysfunction and failure
of the power structure to respond to
climate change people should know
they can take effective action for
themselves by cooperating
with us
to solve a climate problem
by
building this basic demonstration
capability that later on can be
scaled up among many other missions in
space along the way to that
stellar corp will help you do that
um
so at this point i'm going to dive into
some details
on
how we're actually doing what we do what
we've already done
and what we're going to
do in the future
so we've made an early focus
on communications technology and mobile
platforms
because that's something we can reach
immediately so everybody's familiar with
the ham radio
community
and drones and such which i'll get into
in a second so the idea
is to build community
and do real technology development but
on the ground and in the air before you
have to do it in space
because i will tell you having built
green energy teams all over the world
with all kinds of interesting people
the hard part of the equation has always
been the human beings getting the human
beings to work together in a stable way
you solve that you can do anything
so there's a variety of platforms that
can be used fixed you know mobile and
sessile fixed and moving
towers which are fixed
drones that move
balloons of various kinds
tethered balloons
tropospheric balloons free-flying
stratospheric balloons balloons with
rockets in them called raccoons
and
after all that
satellites
the idea
is to leverage
the ham radio community which we have
done on all of us have either gotten or
are getting our tickets as they're
called
leverage the ham radio community which
has a century-long tradition
of public service and cooperation
and
ample spectrum allocation all over the
place so we can learn
technical uh
communication skills and building
hardware
you might ask well there's loads of ham
radio clubs already how are you any
different
well
we're leveraging a concept which in the
big science world or the academic world
kind of a wonky term called user
facilities
we're developing a network of user
facilities almost anything can be
a user facility a user facility
is something physical that you have
that would be useful to other people so
wouldn't it be great if you could use
theirs and they could use yours
so you that's how you build cooperation
and a network of mutual expectation and
performance
at a higher level than the physical user
facilities of using each other's
existing resources
is the joint engineering
of novel
of new facilities new capabilities that
as we get into our space program we
discover
we need
and finally the magic thing about
cooperation
is the sharing of budgets and there are
many kinds of budgets social budgets
people
money
people's time
technical budgets
mass
power
volume
link budget in the in the communication
scheme
learning to share limited resource
so
we're building
this user base this base of users
starting locally and regionally and
extending beyond the around the world
within a few years
because number one we want to have users
on our own spacecraft
and we want to get more people working
that way
and
by doing this for years and getting
people trained up
we build
the personnel pipeline
to
execute to create
a space ecosystem
which i'll
talk about in a minute space ecosystem
so again
the geoengineering demonstrator is not
the only thing we intend to do
other people might want to do other
things and when you cooperate
you let other people achieve their
dreams while they help you achieve your
dreams
so the reason that the user facilities
and the network of user facilities needs
to extend worldwide is
locally you can talk to a drone within
100 meters or you know a kilometer you
can talk to a balloon within tens of
kilometers
to talk to a satellite it's a good idea
to have people in every time zone around
the earth because that's even a low
earth orbit satellite goes all around
the world so every time zone sees every
part of the sky eventually
now recall what i said about cubesats
and a market of
pre-pre-engineered
commercial off-the-shelf components
now
because we're developing one of our
long-term goals is this radiation
levitated craft
no one
has ever demonstrated a pure
pure solar sail
control the attitude in space ever
if you're thinking if the japanese
ikaros they're the only ones to have
come close but that
that was not predominantly a solar sail
that was a heavy thing with a heavy
payload they did get some propulsion
from the solar sail park and they
control their attitude admirably but a
light gossamer sheet
no one's ever managed to
control the edit that's never been done
so on our way to that challenging
mission we're going to run into things
that are not commercially
available off the shelf but we have
provided for a new technology
development program
and indeed in the course of starting up
stellar corp
we've already conceived
multiple
inventions a number of
useful devices which we're
pretty sure don't exist anywhere else
so
uh back to the cubesat for a second
for for items that um
are not commercially off the shelf we've
become this collaborative ecosystem for
new technology development
and
an ecosystem
[Music]
where our
own satellites are in themselves user
facilities in the sense that we can
provide just like people provide us
rides into space
we can provide secondary rides for the
people who want to ride with us
remember a cubesat is about this big
well there are these things called patch
sats which are
chipsets about five by five centimeters
on a side
so if you look
at a 10 centimeter cube you have room
for 16
four
by four by four by four
sixteen ride along chipsets
um there's there's a guy at uh carnegie
mellon who's flown chipsets free flying
so people could ride send their chips
out to ride with us and do their
experiment in space
achieve their dreams and we'll help them
do that
um
getting back to the solar sail for a
minute we we anticipate
these gossamer things the attitude
control
that deploying
a sheet of material
is
actually going to be near the heart of
the technical risk
of the uh
of uh stellar corp and especially the uh
dyson
dot program dyson pico dot program
so where are we
well um
we've been pre-funding
early experiments with
actual user facilities we we own
hardware we've
flown it if you'll notice i had my call
sign at the top of the talk and there's
a device flying around in virginia the
drone with some i mean it's a simple
demonstration
but you can see this anywhere on the web
when it's turned on
we've uh uh working with um
partners we've we're flying payloads on
balloons
so stellar corp has been in
organizational development for about two
years
and we're working out the you know the
timeline and the broad shape of the
mission
and we're now in the phase of
raising money
so how can you get involved there are
specific things we need
there are specific ways for you to get
involved
more people and more money for it goes
without saying
but
a specific need is
to
acquire
and share
space on towers
where you know cell phones have their
packages on towers radio stations have
their packages on towers ham radio
people have packages on towers all over
the country
so tower space is valuable so be great
to acquire and share tower space with
each other
so that this community can learn the
technical skills
both emulation and simulation
and actual physical hardware on towers
which are easy to talk to
another thing you can do
get a ham radio license and if you
already have a ham radio license
be a station operator for other people
who don't yet have one but want to learn
the business of commun electronic
communication
and talking
and i
other than saying ham radio i don't
believe i've mentioned the word radio
once in this talk because coms is a
broader subject like that
another thing you can do
is to build an sdr project
software-defined radio
to work satellite
work with us
get involved
take charge of your lives make a
contribution
to this big challenge facing the human
race
uh about a half century down the road
you can do something useful now
which will lead to a small scale
demonstration
much like
the mrna 10 years 20 years ago and 10
years ago
became very useful to the human race in
the last two years
so i will now take
questions
we've got well actually i'm at your
disposal i'll stay here as long as you
like but we have a we have a good hour
for questions
so um
i'll let
um
[Music]
dr allison be the emcee
and any of the uh live in-person people
you can pose questions as well i have
some backup slides if you want you know
prettier pictures
so go
tell me more
um
the dyson pico dot itself as the word
pico
indicates is a 12 order of magnitude
smaller
demonstration
of the actual device you would need to
cool the planet earth it's the size of
texas whereas the pico dot is the size
of your dinner one trillion dinner
tables
makes texas
but
the dyson pico dot
is
within reach
of a small team thanks to the cubesat
revolution and those other things that
have emerged which means a team of about
a dozen people
over say
five or ten years
can
build the demonstrator and fly it at the
relevant point in space which is on the
sunny side of the sun earth l1 point
prove
the constant that it works that you can
operate there using purely light
pressure and not consuming any fuel
that's the key fuel is expensive so if
you can fly there
operate there communicate with the
device there you've proven what you need
to much like the mrna experiment which
was 99 of the way there
all they had to do at the nih was tweak
it a little and then scale it up by 10
billion
so that's the idea
provide the proof of concept to show
that it can work and if necessary
decades in the future you know in place
of in case of fire break glass
there is a capability but if we wait to
50 years in the future and say oh we got
to build solar sails
how are they going to ramp up to
something the size of texas
in that amount of time so
as dr allison would say we
don't have the luxury of time
we do have a few decades to get this
done
but we don't have decades to waste
but these remarkable
emergencies
cubesats and small cooperative projects
and people working from home
that has shown we can get started
productively now on this long-term
technology
demonstration program and it's it's a
practical program which will
lead to
a useful end result
a decade hence
which may provide
the baseline the basis of an
intervention global intervention
three decades hence
and even more important
it will build
community
technical cooperative community around
the world for executing other projects
that haven't been thought of
for example if i may
elaborate i said at the top
governments are incapable have proven
themselves incapable of dealing with
climate change
there are other transnational global
threats that are also not being dealt
with
marine plastic pollution
the collapse of the ocean fisheries
in our field
space junk
nobody's doing anything constructive
about it
so that's why people are disappointed
anyway not to mention nuclear
proliferation and all those things
so
another question please
because we've done the calculation and
it's it's about the size of texas
a texas is one quarter of one percent of
the circular area of earth
it may be you need two percent which is
10 texas
the answer is somewhere
somewhere in between but we know from
the historical record
that a one quarter of one percent
decline in sunlight
caused the little ice age in northern
europe that we know because it's a thing
called the maunder minimum
okay and i'll illustrate the magnitude
of the maunder minimum
everybody knows about the solar max min
cycle
everybody knows about the solar max min
cycle which is about
1 000th
of the sun's output
fluctuates over an 11-year period the
easy way to visualize this is take two
reams of xerox paper that's a thousand
sheets and it's the thickness of one
sheet of paper that's the variation
one sheet of paper on the two rings
the monitor minimum
three sheets of paper
we know
from historical records from paris
records from
things that people kept
that the sunspot count went to zero
and
europe northern europe declined over two
degrees fahrenheit
and population stalled crops failed etc
so we know that intervention somewhere
between a quarter of a percent perhaps
as much as two percent
will do it
it will basically a rheostat that dials
back global warming enough
it doesn't do anything
about the carbon habit
or acidification of the oceans
some folks think it's a moral hazard
to come up with a solution that gets you
out of
confronting your you know your substance
abuse problem but
that's that's sophistry when you know
the house is burning down
you need you need to act you need to put
a capability in place
uh dr allison can you uh
be the emcee and
read the uh questions in the chat box
while he's doing that i'll take another
question from the live audience
in person
we thought about that
that's in here
so please everything can you repeat the
question nobody uh yes on zoom can you
hear the question was
have you thought about the materials of
construction of the full scale dot
why yes we have
that's partly where our mass budget came
from
so
uh everybody thinks
aluminized mylar but actually uh solar
radiation would
blast the heck out of mylar in just a
few years
um
what we do have in space
mother nature's funny
the way elements the abundance of
elements are in the cosmos you might
think oh aluminum would be a great thing
to build this
reflective mirror out of
in fact there's three times as much
magnesium
in the cosmos as there is
aluminum so if you go into space and
you're harvesting space resources and
you're doing metals production you know
reduction and fabrication
for large lightweight stuff you're
probably going to use magnesium
which has got as good a strength to
weight ratio as aluminum and it's a lot
more available
and either way the lunar regolith
is
oxides of aluminum and oxides of
magnesium and oxides of titanium
so there's plenty of those light
middleweight metals to go around
well
this
object that's being pictured and uh if
you would click one more to the thing
the size of that
that object
is a hundred million tons
even a sheet of foil
the size of texas would be a hundred
million tons
to lift 100 million tons
off of
planet earth
well let me put it this way
guess would anybody care to guess since
the begin since october 4th
1957
how much mass have human beings
permanently put into space and by
permanently i mean i don't mean like
the space shuttle that went up and came
down i mean the stuff that they brought
up and that they left there how much
mass
take a guess
we have a thousand tons any other
guesses
did you say 10 tons
okay any other guests
okay
well that's a nice bracket
and
is the closest
the answer is about 10 000 tons
so
in 60 years
the sum total of the satellites the deep
space probes the junk
10 thousand tons more or less
the sheet of foil the size of texas is
ten thousand times that ten thousand
times ten thousand is a hundred million
so
to lift off of planet earth in the next
few decades
10 000 times what we have lifted off in
the previous 60 years
seems like a stretch
i'm guessing
there had there have been there have
been other proposals uh one proposal was
for five trillion with a t
things the size of a phonograph record
that would be optical defractors and
steer them around a little
what's the cost to raise a ton
right now um ten thousand dollars a
kilogram and it's
it's
yeah
yeah and if they ever get their star
whatever they call it built it might
drop to
um
a thousand and that's just a lift dr
allison
because
yeah it's only ten percent
don't worry about it
we're we're not gonna we're not gonna
mess with the uh you know
anything beyond the decimal point
then i'll take some questions by the
chat box i imagine there's quite a few
no
yeah
another reason is yeah
how would you now look
this is
size of texas is just for talking point
people just understand the scale of the
intervention in fact what you would do
is you build many of them
the people in three decades four decades
hence after we have proven to them
that it can be done
three or four decades hence
they uh
might build
items the size of a city which is a
square kilometer or ten square
kilometers or maybe the size of a county
which is a thousand square kilometers so
they may build thousands of them and
they may build a million of them that's
for them to decide
but the advantage of building lots of
little ones
is
build a little learn a little
learn by doing
and the other advantage of building lots
of little ones is
every little one you put up
you get an incremental
anti-climate change benefit whereas you
don't have to wait
like unlike a power plant say or nuclear
power plant you don't have to wait until
this multi-billion dollar investment is
complete before you see any economic
benefit
by building a number of small ones and
learning along the way you generate
the economic benefit pay as you go
rather than
might have been a combination
because the little ice age was quite
harsh
it lasted
three maybe four centuries
now
one thing that would let the volcano
volcano may have contributed
but volcanic effects don't last
centuries
unless the volcanic event is so huge it
creates a nuclear winter for instance
the toba eruption
off the island of
either java or sumatra 74 000 years ago
created a thousand-year nuclear
no
weapon
wasn't actually nuclear but
a thousand years
and it almost took out the human race in
fact it killed every human being who
managed to walk out of africa before
74 000 years ago they all died so we had
to walk out of africa again
so toba did that
snowball that's like 700 million years
ago that's the the devonian
there was a period
50 million years ago
when the earth was quite hot even after
the dinosaurs got killed the earth was
still hot
and then
um in the arctic ocean some some um
patch like duckweed but it's actually a
tiny fern called azola
now the one thing about the arctic ocean
that's interesting
is it's land it's essentially landlocked
it's hardly connected to the world
oceans at all just look at a turn of
globe and look at the nose you'll see
the arctic ocean is almost completely
surrounded and all the major continental
rivers north of like the 45th parallel
flow north and dump into it which means
the arctic ocean is very nutrient rich
and it's cold
and what happens with cold
cold salt water sinks right
and fresh water sits on top
so you had kind of warm brackish
nutrient-rich
fresh water on top
fed by all the rivers flowing in so then
this little weed got started
and it spread over the
arctic ocean in a flash
it would cover it in a year
and then northern winter would happen
and the weed would die the little ferns
would die and they would sink to the
bottom into the ooze and the next summer
it would happen again and again and
again
and in less than 1 million years
the earth's concentration of carbon
dioxide in the atmosphere went from
about
3 500 parts per million
it dropped 80 percent
to about 700 parts per million and we
have never gone back since
so 49 million years ago the earth had a
permanent transition
to a
cooler earth
and to put the 700 in perspective
we passed 400 million not too long ago
400 per million
and you know we're headed
get it backed up so this little
insignificant little plant
fundamentally changed the planetary
planetology
and geology of earth it's down there in
the record it's one reason that there's
so many
petrochemical resources
in the arctic that's why people drill
there because all the stuff
is in the ooze and got turned into oil
no actually pre-industrial was
i'm gonna say 280
yeah yeah i i don't know what happened
to the 700 down to the 300 but you know
right so uh uh
asked um
he thought the pre-industrial level was
350 parts per million and i correct him
it's close you were only off 20
yes sir
what was the time uh
of the
project in space
what would be the lifetime project in
space
and do you intend to uh
why don't i answer the first one and you
figure out
okay though well the last part's easy no
would it be the point
right it takes propellant and you know
no
yeah
no it'd be pointless to bring it back to
earth
um
so the lifetimes
uh
we've we've envisioned a stepwise
private space program
once
we're well on the way of building a
community with terrestrial assets fixed
and mobile remember towers drones
balloons the next step
like 12 year olds in our town did
is small cubesats in leo
right to prove the team
can
produce a satellite
interface with the beer deal with the
bureaucracy because if it's space you've
got to learn how to deal with
bureaucracy
which a lot of open source movements
don't know how to do
don't have the patience to do
so that's another way we're different
so
small cubesats in leo
but these cubesats wouldn't be just a
stunt
they would demonstrate some principles
for instance flying two at a time you
would demonstrate formation form
if you can get far enough up in leo
you might be able to generate
enough solar propulsive force
that using a really good clock you could
measure
the difference in velocity it's it's not
much
for example that japanese project
12 years ago that flew the students
built it in two and a half years
for 20 million dollars which is actually
completely remarkable for an
interplanetary mission
it's astounding
they flew this spacecraft which was
about the size of this room
they flew it to venus now mostly the
spacecraft hitched a ride
on another japanese interplanetary
mission and that's where it got 99 of
its delta v
but the straight-up solar part
over eight months
that solar sail
generated about 100 meters per second of
delta v
but it took him eight months
so in leo you'd be looking at you know
much smaller so you need really good
measurement
there are other things we can do in leo
communications uh testing
non-rf communications
formation flying
[Music]
uh one
potential is what we call the van allen
express
which when we're done with the
experiment you have the little thing
raise its orbit on purpose and fly
through the van allen belt and kill
itself but
everybody's getting telemetry
to see because nobody voluntarily flies
into the van allen
i mean on purpose
but
you know it's sort of like a mind-going
uh um d mining a field by you know
stomping
geo
there are things we can do now in geo
you could almost certainly start
measuring
the delta v from solar propulsion and
demonstrate formation flying
and interface
with bureaucracy because once again geo
is extremely valuable
real estate it's like having an office
building on el camino real so you know
everybody's going to get involved
it's a it's a sensitive area and geo is
a place
where we can hitch a ride to
in the beginning of our program we're
going to be you know as the germans say
mocking auto stops
we're going to be hitching rocks
maybe later on we'll have our own
launchers
conceivable
not impossible
beyond geo though
beyond geo
there aren't
you can't get free rides
so if you want to go to the vicinity of
the moon this is called cis lunar space
between the earth's hill sphere
and the moon is called cislunar space
and if you want a ride
you have to pay somebody else who's
already going there for commercial or
military reasons and the cost is three
hundred thousand dollars per kilogram
which is
remember those students in oak ridge
built their entire satellite for seventy
thousand dollars a one kilogram
satellite
so that's pretty stiff and if you want
to land on the moon
million dollars a kilogram
and if you want to go
to the sun earth lagrange point
or the earth
trojans presently you have to hitch a
ride
and that's going to set you back a cool
million dollars per kilogram
and if you can think of some other
clever way to do it
sure but but that clever way no matter
how you do it you might have a team of
engineers who's doing something clever
but guess what you have to pay a team of
engineers to sit at their computers for
two three four years
guess what you're back at the moon
it's like the third it's like the laws
of thermodynamics you know
you can't win you can't break even and
you can't leave the game
so
but
one thing that has emerged in the cube's
cubesat space
are these small engines
about yay
the size of two cubesats put together
and the great thing about such a small
engine
is if you have a large enough propellant
tank
and with this engine with a small engine
and enough propellant and it's very high
performance
uh it's uh
two 2000 seconds
at least
the great thing about this engine means
it offers the possibility to get a small
payload our payload up to where it needs
to be
by itself
that's phenomenal that has not been done
before
so imagine now
everybody knows you can hitch a ride
into leo easy peasy nasa has a huge
program for you know the cubesat program
they will give you the ride for free if
you organize your team a certain way
improve you're not going to waste nasa's
time
if you show that you're running things
which the oakridge students did
nasa gives you the ride that's worth 100
or 200 grand it's great
everybody can get to leo hitch a ride to
leo
and some people can hitch a ride to geo
but anywhere else
it's hard so imagine what it's going to
do
for small team science in engineering
and technology development of small
teams of people of 10 to 20
dedicated people can get into a region
of space that has never been gotten to
by a small team before
something that jpl has been doing for 60
years now being done by
a dozen people you know
something barely larger than a garage
imagine what's going to happen
well you don't have to imagine very hard
because here we are in silicon valley
which
partly was started by
two guys in a garage right
yep
that's the story it's a good it's a good
uh origin story
so we have another question
thank you for coming
well
the premise
of our program and of our non-profit
is that governments ain't doing the job
and there's there's there's a serious
problem that's not being addressed
effectively or in a timely way because
governments
are not cooperating i mean governments
can certainly command the resources
they could if they wanted to but
apparently they don't you know partly
because they're beholden to
unrepresentative special interests so
smaller teams of people now have the
ability
to make contributions improve technology
that will ultimately be scaled up
by very large cooperation at some point
in the future decades hence
but we're providing both
a technical demonstration
like
this idea technically it's feasible it
can work we've proven the principle
and we're providing a model of
grassroots open source non-proprietary
cooperation
based on community and mutual
expectation
at a human scale
would be salubrious
well
think of linux
how is linux govern how is how is a how
is an open source community project like
linux governed
how was the internet created in the
first place with the internet
engineering task force
was volunteers
got together and agreed on standards of
behavior they agreed on technical
standards
and whatever
bottom-up government governance
is perfectly possible
you don't need top-down bureaucratic
governance that's that's that's a relic
of
the agricultural revolution when you
know kings and priests controlled the
grain output because those were the only
people who knew how to write
or the early industrial era where
everything was mass production mass
production lines and uh taylorism at the
watertown arsenal now everything was
mass production you need armies of
workers
you know being actual armies you know
con
cooperation has always had
two broad styles
both called cooperation
one style of cooperation is called
collaboration
that's where people
who are
relatively even in the org chart all
pitch in
to help out on common tap because they
all know a little about the overall task
that's to be done that's a very flat
pyramid
and then the other style of cooperation
perfectly valid is called coordination
and coordination is where well okay you
do a then you do b then you do
do d that's more like a traditional
factory
which is also a valid way of organizing
things and for a space project
you would need both and at the front end
of our non-profit of stellar court we
are absolutely collaborative
everybody knows a little bit about
something and we all pitch in
on what's
to be done
later on when you're building the bird
and especially when you're interfacing
with bureaucracy and making sure the
paper works correct
that becomes more like
coordination things have to happen in a
stepwise way
so the front obviously is more
democratic and the latter is
somewhat more authoritarian but not more
authoritarian than it has to be
by the way i am
i've been remiss
i believe there are several members of
stellar court
k3 at stellarcorp.tv
at the very beginning
k3
you know
yeah
and um
i think uh
um
everything here i think we was touched
on
there are uh
considerations of uh a little uh ice age
and uh
volcanic eruptions and corresponds that
sort of thing but they're all things
that can be dealt with offline
we're going to the
we're having the
grand opening
early june june 11th
so uh anybody who wants to come call me
first
make sure it's on don't buy plane ticket
until i tell you to
but our plan is to have the grand
opening
june 11th in oak ridge tennessee
and
uh we're going to the small satellite
we're doing a lot of learning this
summer going to the small satellite
conference in utah
and
i'm going to be
doing
this talk
uh preparing for you dr allison has been
salubrious
and necessary for it forced us to think
so
we're asked we're asking for money
right away
and we will just continue to do that
we're
probably going to be in proposal hell
for several years
investigating all these sources
we know there's private foundations
we're very much into the same vision
there's even governmental entities who
you know we can be
we can be sputniks right fellow
travelers
for a while
oh and and
our technical work
has not stopped
before
long before the speech we're already
buying hardware and flying it we're
going to continue to do that all right
the whole time
and
it's in a stepwise form
greater and greater to technical
sophistication so first
software-defined radio and satellite
emulators which is all software but very
soon after that
physical dipoles
simulating
on the ground or in the air
how an actual bird in space tumbles and
its antennas are tumbling and how do you
how do you talk to antennas that are
tumbling well you can make antennas
tumble on a drone and learn
what that behavior is learn how to adapt
to it you can do that right now
here on the ground
for example so we have you know
immediately we have a three-year program
of these
staggered
you know technical learning
sub-programs
we're all we're going to be busy
meanwhile not losing sight of the love
building the organization
building the website
building the means
for people to share facilities
fairly
without favoritism and you know good
standards of behavior
do you have a timeline for when things
are going to happen when yes because
i think uh you've uh
you've alluded to the same 50 year old
in the future uh days that every project
that's never going to be
trying to
i
personally think that
the dates of
near disaster are very much closer than
well
this isn't going to take anything like
50 years
if anybody's got that impression
no no no our program
is
ten ish give or take a few
right with a three-year program
right up front that we are already
engaged in of community building network
building technical capable building a
user facility getting them recruited and
on board
three years of fairly intense activity
of that
before
engineers starting to engineer
the first bird into leo and that might
take two years to execute so
notionally and this is just
notionally
2027 for an asset in
leo might be sooner i don't expect it to
be later could be sooner if we get lucky
and then after that about a year and a
half to two year cadence
just like the apollo program
build a little learn a little because
hardware trumps all
now
you're focused
geographically
that's where we're starting
can i i would like to tell you a little
story about that
uh dr allison said geographically you're
focused around oak ridge and that was
just the lead-in comment
so may i address and then you can give
me the second half of the question
two years ago we conceived our original
conception was we're going to have to
look all over earth because when i do
green energy i'm all over the earth and
in fact i happen to know
if some of my
genius teammates from africa are on the
call
i know people all over the earth
and i certainly hope to get them
involved
one day as soon as possible
but we realized a year ago when we saw a
bunch of 12 year olds put up a satellite
which no one had even been talking about
it was a it wasn't much of a surprise to
me honestly as
anyone you don't know what you don't
know
but when we realize that 12 year olds
can do this we realize
we don't have to look much beyond 30 to
100 miles from where we live we like all
all the resources are there which is
great because that's also the scale of
the initial
user facilities and sharing is on the
county
fragmentary state level so that's why
we're starting small but
i mean limited geographic scope remember
i said
ultimately to talk to something in space
you need eyes and ears in every time
zone so what's the second half of your
question
oh
i don't know
sat nags does it
sat nags is an international
organization
um remember what i said about build
build a little learn a little
managing the growth
is absolutely
key to amy
right enterprise that's going to be
successful is to handle the growth
problem
one thing i do know because we've mapped
this out
with labor hours
and dollars
on the space program side of things in
other words the engineering technical
side of things we've mapped out
a 15-year program
and at no point
does our resource burn
get crazy
and the progression
of satellite experiment of satellite
spacecraft experiments
on a law semi-log scale proceeds
uniformly without any
suspicious like and then a miracle
happens kind of thing
it's remarkably linear
on a semi-log scale over the 15 years
yet the burn rate in terms of labor
hours
and dollars
is
not much more than plus minus a factor
of two
which is fairly steady so that means the
pacing
of the spacecraft construction part
design the engineering and the launch
and the operation the pacing of that
is um sustainable
but a social
program
the networking
that may end up growing like those asola
weeds
we may have a tiger by the tail
five years hence
it could happen again look at silicon
valley
these things happen
we'll be watching
we've developed a set of metrics
the wonky word is key performance indica
indicators we heard a lot of that at a
missile mark
we've developed a small set of kpis that
we're tracking to watch well if this
thing really takes off
can we can we can we manage it and just
like the climate change problem
do we have personnel in place
who are ready
to step in and
manage it my personal ambitions
to be mission director on you know when
the bird finally gets to seo one
and actually there was an earlier
question
about
the longevity right which i didn't
completely answer
we have two things that we're going to
put at seo one one first and one second
at seo one itself
will be a long duration like by long i
mean decade a station
that moves a little
but can be can talk to
when you're not having to point your
radio antenna or other comms device
directly at the sun
because at the l1 point there are these
things called halo orbits
where you move around but you're still
you don't get too far away
so that
object
it's intended that it be there for a
decade
and serve
um
it's
it has two importances one is to
demonstrate a little photonic propulsion
but also to be this
radio
test bed and experimenter's platform
what the amateur ham radio people call
an oscar
so a long duration oscar at
seo one and then
following that the true solar sail
for physical reasons
i
won't get into but they're sort of uh
andrew if you'll go to the
thing with the angles and the earth and
the sun
the balance point
of something
levitated by radiation isn't actually at
the seo one point it's on the sunny side
of it
in essence
physically
the radiation pushing on
the sail transferring its momentum to
the sail
makes the spacecraft think
that the sun
has lost weight
but the sun has lost weight if the sun
were more massive you'd go around it
faster
if the sun were less massive you would
go around it slower
it's it's in essence it's
decelerating a little bit the entire
time
in orbit so
physically it's equivalent to if the sun
weighs a little bit less
and that is why
it's able to stay on the inside lane of
the freeway
but never get ahead of you
like a car on the freeway that was on
the inside lane on a curb gets ahead of
you just like planets do
but with radiation be using light
you can slow yourself down a little bit
and keep
pace keep
lock
with some body
further out
so that's
that's the culmination of that
particular
satellite program the one that's aimed
at demonstrating
the capability for climate change
and that's
10-year probably no sooner than 10 years
15 years maximum
[Music]
which still leaves people of the future
25 more years to take that
and do their thing which is scale it up
not just build copies but just having
that principle in mind like having pcr
in mind you know we now
know how to do all these wonderful
things genetically so it's to prove that
capability and then they have
25 or
so years
to do the scale up which
they should do they should be able to do
the internet group
by that order
over that period of time
any more questions
um one person wanted to know if you were
to look at the planetary society's solar
field
yes the planetary society is a
remarkably flat organization and they
are definitely
more toward the collaborative end of the
cooperation scale than the coordination
in so
and the other thing they have
is a extraordinary amount of patience
because that solar sail is about the
[Music]
fifth or sixth time
they try to get a solar
sail into
orbit or a cooperative space mission of
some kind they used to work with the
russian space agency all the time and
every single one of those missions came
to not through
you know
force measure
a launcher went bad somebody pushed the
wrong button whatever i mean they those
folks have learned to live with
disappointment
yet not lose sight of their mission and
they keep going it's it's really
admirable so they finally got something
in space which by the way it's cubesat
based
tumbles but i mean they didn't
okay we got a solar thing into space so
check
now to control it that's that's going to
be hard that's requires very serious
mathematics
i'm not sure a very flat organization is
going to come up with that that sounds
more academic to me
definitely not flat
well the folks
long now
have a project to build a 10 000 year
car
and the big problem with that is not the
mechanics so much as the people to
maintain it
and the same problem with this here
this is a long-term project which
ends up being
uh
texas
and does this mean that
part of your uh your
project is uh how do you know something
well
we have a fine example
in current not separated by a vast
amount of time in history
i offer you the example of the dutch
dike builders
the dutch have been
saving their lives
by engineering their landscape
to save their lives literally if
anyone's ever heard of doggerland i'll
talk about that in a minute
but
you know the whole north sea area used
to be occupied by people
until the seas rose
so the dutch
for 800 maybe even a thousand years have
been cooperating
on building dikes to save their lives
building dikes
and they have continued this cooperation
they have maintained their mission they
have maintained their technical focus
they have maintained their personal
pipeline across eight maybe 10 centuries
despite
all these changes of governance that the
actual dutch nation went through
holland at one point was
part of the spanish empire
they've been a republic they've been on
like a senatorial republic they've been
a monarchy they've been
every kind of thing
yet the remarkable thing is that the
technical mission in the technical
society continued unabated so that is
and of course the dutch are among the
most collaborative people on earth so
that is absolutely
a long-term example you know in the
interstellar field for example where
missions might go a few hundred years
you're gonna have to build institutions
that maintain focus
technical focus
and stay on the job generation after
generation after generation well
it's been done and they're not the only
one but they're very much
the most on point one because they do it
to cope with a hostile climate and not
die
oh
i don't think anything here is not ever
handled
thank you very much
[Applause]